um i'd like to introduce chris
you will be talking to us about
um
uh some uh
network uh and in interference
uh from linear to low degree polynomial
models
times all yours
thank you so much um i'm uh well i'm
really excited to share this with you
it's a it's my first time talking about
it so i'm really eager to get um you
know
feedback and
thoughts from you know
so i'll start with a i guess a little
toy example so suppose you're
working for the new york department of
health and you are want to run a
campaign to a public health campaign to
encourage people to wear masks at the
beginning at the peak of the uh or
hopefully before the peak of the
covid um uh pandemic
and uh you want to you know you solicit
for a set of ads that um you know
various creators propose and you want to
ask which ad is most effective
so
ideally what you want to do is kind of
estimate what i'm going to refer to as a
total treatment effect it's the
difference between these two
hypothetical scenarios where suppose i
have like i have some billboard space
and i can choose to put one ad up and
everyone when i put that up everyone
sees that ad so either everyone sees
this particular ad
for a public health ad for
wearing masks or some other
unrelated ad which i'll call the control
and what we want to estimate is this
total treatment effect or the average
difference in the total outcome where
for example total outcome might be
something like
how many people are wearing masks after
after the treatment uh versus
how many people would be would have worn
masks anyways uh whether or not they saw
the treatment
and so a naive thing you could do is to
say well you know nowadays i can do
online ad campaigns why don't i run a b
test online where you know there's some
random traffic and uh every a user that
arrives you know
gets shown an ad either
either the treatment ad or the control
ad and and then i measure the outcome um
let's say
maybe through uh whether they respond on
facebook to like putting up i don't know
putting some
masking pro masking uh symbol up on
their facebook page or something um
and so
to talk i guess to introduce notation
i'll be using uh here the individual is
uh kind of indexed by eye the treatment
uh so the
variable zi is going to be one if the
individual i gets a treatment and the
variable zi is 0 if the individual eye
is placed in control and
here this function y sub i this is going
to be our potential outcomes for this
individual
and it's a function of whether or not
this individual got the treatment right
so y sub i uh evaluated at one is the
outcome if the individual got the
treatment y sub i evaluated at zero is
if the individual got control
and the naive thing to do or so and a
critical assumption that i kind of made
already in the notation here is that
that i've assumed the outcome only
depends on the individual's own
treatment which is called the stable
unit treatment value assumption and so
i've already made that assumption even
in the notation here the fact that this
potential outcome is only a function of
the individual's treatment
so under this case the total treatment
effect would be the same as the
difference between these two quantities
again the average over the all outcomes
if if everyone was treated minus average
overall outcomes if
if everyone was not treated and a naive
thing to do or just i mean a simple
thing to do a natural thing to do maybe
i'll call a natural thing to do is to
compute a difference in means estimator
where i would just compute the um after
i do this randomized experiment i
compute the average outcomes amongst all
individuals that were assigned to
treatment minus the average outcome of
all individuals that were assigned to
control
and um you know randomization is
important to get unbiasedness and to
kind of break any confounding effects
because you're truly running a
randomized experiment so you know that
there's no
relationship between
how an individual was signed and their
outcome and uh but this critically
relies on this
assumption so this stable unit treatment
value assumption
and so
in this talk we really want to focus in
on how to deal with network interference
so what if an individual's outcome is a
function of the treatment of his or her
neighbor so for example here
you know let's say
this grandpa is wearing a mask it could
have a negative effect on this teenage
boy on the
right but maybe a positive effect on the
neighbor
on the left
and the issue is that once you introduce
this network interference you have to be
very careful a lot of the a lot of the
uh classical results um
you know do not hold
and so just to be clear about what the
um
the challenge is now once we introduce
network interference the we have to kind
of update the notation so the potential
outcomes function here why i is now
function not only of my treatment but
also the treatment of everyone else so
uh here the uh i'm
the total treatment effect now is the
average outcomes uh the average the
difference between average outcomes if
everyone's treated minus everyone's in
control but what happens is that when i
randomly assign individuals to treatment
and control what i really observe what i
measure as a result of the experiment is
um the out potential is outcome of
individual if they're treated and
whatever happened to be the treatment
assignment of his or her neighborhood
um and so in particularly uh if if the
treatment assignment of his or her
neighborhood does not exactly like does
not fully match uh the individual's
treatment then that means the opposite
observed outcome is not either of these
outcomes that we want to
observe that actually form our estimate
um
all right um i guess any questions about
the setup
um and so without uh further assumptions
um
on the on the model um the the best you
can do is to look at estimators that are
limited to only use information measured
from
the sets of individuals for which the
the individual and their treatment their
and then
their entire neighborhood get the same
treatment and so you're looking for
individuals where
the individual and all of his neighbors
are assigned to control or the
individual and all of his neighbors are
assigned to treatment and that
guarantees that the measured outcome is
indeed one of these quantities in your
estimate that you want to estimate
but the the kind of the limitation as
you can see is that you do lose
statistical power because there's only a
few measurements that you're even able
to use after you run the experiment and
um and so you know often is done is
actually to think of clever ways of
designing randomized designs that help
to
boost up the probabilities of those
events um but that can be actually
computationally challenging for complex
networks uh and and so yeah this is
still a very um kind of interesting uh
yeah uh challenge to deal with so to uh
let me guys start stepping into the
results um
first i'm gonna set up a little bit of
notation so again
i'm going to use a potential outcomes
model where y sub i denotes the outcome
of individual i under
supha the degrees of freedom in the
model is just 2 times n because for each
individual i have to define this
function that just maps from a binary
treatment or control to an outcome
but under
under what we're going to assume is
neighborhood inference meaning my my
outcome is only a function of my
treatment and the treatment of a
neighborhood of individuals around me
the degrees of freedom of my potential
outcomes model is now 2 to the d times n
so you can see you get a exponential
blow up in the complexity of your model
and
on the other hand the total number of
observations if i ran a single
experiment no matter how clever i am
i can only get n measurements so one
measurement from each individual
and the goal is to estimate the total
treatment effect
and um
kind of the very minimal assumptions
that you you need is actually already
made it here in this here i already
imposed a neighborhood interference
assumption there's ways of generalizing
this type of assumption that uh the idea
is that uh
if i want to measure that the outcome of
an individual under the event that
everyone is treated uh when i'm take it
run an experiment and obviously not
everyone is treated i need to have some
events under which uh the the outcome is
still the same so under a neighborhood
interference assumption is saying that
if at least my neighbors are treated
then
my measured outcome is consistent with
what would happen if everyone is treated
and there's generalizations of that
concept
and so uh to give a baseline i just want
to say what what would be the like the
first thing you might want to try and
uh this is a um so here i'm just using a
hearts thompson estimator it's an
inverse propensity score estimator where
here um
the uh
i'm multiplying by the indicator
function of whether or not uh this
individual eye and its neighborhood are
all treated and i'm dividing it by the
probability of that event and i'm
subtracting off this again indicator of
whether the individual and all its
neighborhood is not treated and divided
by the probability of that event
uh under i'm gonna sorry so i'm gonna
assume under also the most naive
randomized design is for newly designed
so each individual is treated
independently with probability p uh if
that's the case then the this expression
for the probability of everyone being
treated or in control kind of simplifies
to this product and you can calculate
the variance so so this is an unbiased
estimator first of all because well
because of the by construction with the
inverse propensity scores
but the uh the variance here you can see
it scales with p to the d and d is the
degree of the
uh
of the node and so it has an exponential
blow up in the degree of um
of the individuals in the graph and and
that ends up being very costly
uh p is the problem yes so here i'm just
going to assume uniform
yeah
uniform so there's definitely smarter
things you can do
but here i'm just starting with the very
first thing you could try which is
uniform bernoulli
so a natural question is can we do
better
and there's uh
actually quite a lot of um uh
um work in this space and um i'm i'm
really kind of breezed by it very fast
but um
i'm gonna classify them into kind of two
categories one i'm gonna call
non-parametric approaches that they most
of them focus on designing clever
randomized designs uh that you know try
to boost up that that probability that
you get uh to observe individuals and
all their neighborhood in the same
treatment or control but the solutions
depend heavily on the grass structure um
and so for example one common assumption
is that you have uh fully disconnected
groups so this i mean this is uh
reasonable in many settings where let's
say you have a type of effect where
effects can only happen within
households and there cannot be effect
across households this would be a
reasonable assumption to make and then
that would allow you to say that well
because now i have like fully
disconnected households in some way i
can almost treat each household almost
like a unit right
and another approach is to
use graph clustering so imagine i have a
network here what i would do is i pick a
set of individuals that are hopefully a
far ish apart and and then i kind of
look i cluster the graph by assigning
each
individual to the closest
cluster center and then once i have
these clusters then i randomize over the
clusters jointly meaning each one of
these clusters gets assigned fully to
treated or fully to control and what
that what that does is it makes sure
that any individual that's in the
interior of the clusters
their treatment and the neighbor's
treatment are always aligned and that
makes sure that i get you know hopefully
i get more informative measurements
right um
uh and the the kind of i guess the
comment i want to make is the custering
approaches they are computationally it
can be competition costly and um they do
kind of hinge on very specific
properties of your graph so you're
assuming your graph is clusterable and
um that may they may be true they may
not be true and
it uh um and and so yeah in this talk
i'll be looking for something a little
bit more general
in terms of graph structure
another approach that i'll bucket a
large class of approaches into is what
i'll call parametric approaches and
uh these are settings in which um
the they're imposed we impose um
assumptions on the model such that that
kind of reduce the degrees of freedom of
the model such as the degrees of freedom
of the model are significantly smaller
than the number of measurements so our
number of measurements was n we assume a
simplified model let's say the simplest
one is suppose my outcomes is linear in
the number of my neighbors are treated
right so in that sense i have some
covariate it's the number of neighbors
treated and i have like one parameter i
need to estimate which is the like the
coefficient of that the slope of that
right and and in that sense you can in
that case you can imagine that it's
actually fairly easy to uh
estimate you can use a variety of
regression style methods you can also
make the model a little bit more complex
use machine learning methods but the but
the key uh limitation is that you have
to start with a class of models that um
where the parameters in your model are
like significantly smaller than n
so that you can actually fully identify
it
and as such it also can be more fragile
to model the specification
all right and one last comment i want to
make is that all pretty much all the
approaches above they do require a pro
at least approximate knowledge of the
network if not complete knowledge the
network so if i want to do around a kind
of a clever cluster randomized design i
need to know the neighborhood
if i want to
fit a regression style
you know
a model i need to also measure i need to
know how many neighbors are treated at
this individual so i need to know their
neighborhood as well
so one that's one thing we we're going
to want to deal with in this talk today
is when what happens when you don't have
knowledge of the network and then and
the other
comment i want to make is that um
uh the kind of results that i'm going to
talk about today is looking at a
non-parametric setting so we're going to
have a class of models in which the
number of parameters is significantly
higher than your measurements so you
cannot expect to fully identify so you
cannot use machine learning methods
however
we're not going to rely heavily on graph
structure instead we're going to think
about uh can we impose model structure
that
and figure out how to exploit that model
structure but not so restrictive that we
move into the parametric world so that
will come become explicit in a bit yeah
i want to clarify a little bit um
what you mean by
parametric here because
sometimes i have like a functional form
on the outcomes
um
and i assume that the coefficients maybe
are shared
across all the units but sometimes the
coefficients have the subscript i and in
the one case
maybe they both look like
str like structural but one of them yes
non-parametric and one of them looks
very much yeah and that's some
approaches are these do these not have
little eyes or do you think that even
the little eyes are considered parallel
so the here the parametric ones do not
have the lines so it'll be something or
maybe instead of little eyes it might be
something like my coefficient is a
function of my covariates and my
coverage observed and so maybe i cannot
have a separate parameter for every
individual but i'm allowed to have
separate parameters for each group of
covariates but i then i need yeah
coverage
but uh that's exactly the style of model
we're going to look at actually
so
great so our question is in the presence
of network interference does there exist
a simple and efficient solution for
estimating a total treatment effect that
does not critically rely on the
knowledge of the network structure
however our solution is going to require
imposing some kind of appropriate model
assumptions so wait for that
um so the the quick preview of what
we're able to show is that uh so there's
two parts of our assumptions the first
part is the first line so assume we have
knowledge of the average baseline i'll
comment on that in a moment
so this average baseline is the average
outcome under the control purely control
then if i use this
bernoulli randomized design so i could
really just take each individual
independently assign them to treatment
or control measure their outcome and
then construct my estimate by taking the
average over all the observed outcomes
minus out the
average baseline and then scale it by
one over p
and so
this estimator i'm going to say
plus here i've written i've hidden it
still a suitable model so that i'm going
to have an explained assumption under
which this estimator is unbiased and its
variance scales as d squared over p n p
times n so the the the kind of
scaling with the degree is polynomial uh
or i mean also just squared simple one
and we will not need to have assumptions
on the graph
uh
and so comment on the first the first
bullet point um there so that that may
be uh something you don't want to assume
i'm gonna actually mention at the very
end that we can actually relax that but
uh but for for now let's just say one
could this be reasonable uh we could
have estimates of the average baseline
from historical data or pilot surveys or
and this is fairly easy to collect this
data before the experiment begins
because it doesn't actually require any
experimentation right so we're only
measuring something passively about the
control uh before but um
it does imply that the outcomes before
you run the experiment and during is
kind of the same so it doesn't
allow for time fixed effects
okay so now i'm going to tell you the
model so of course this is the critical
piece what model makes this work and
um here i'm going to look at a model
that i'm going to call it a
heterogeneous linear outcomes model
where your outcome is a a linear
functional of the treatments of you and
your neighbors so in particular it can
be is the sum of uh an individual
baseline effect that's alpha i
and then an individual direct treatment
effect that's going to be beta i if i
was treated in my direct [ __ ] on me and
then for each one of my neighbors
there's going to be a coefficient gamma
ki which is if my neighbor k was treated
what's their effect on me
and so the the most critical part of the
assumption of these networks effects are
additive that make and it's uh
and yeah the additive across my
neighbors and so you can you can think
of this model as you can write in matrix
vector form where the the outcomes is
equal to this vector of the baselines
plus this matrix this matrix has the
betas on the diagonal and the gammas on
the off diagonal times the treatment
vector
and another way to visualize this model
is to think of a graph here on the right
where i have alphas are kind of labeled
at the node and then every edge the self
edges have a label which is the betas
and then every edge between pairs of
nodes is uh has the weight which comes
from the gamma
um and and so when an individual is
treated i'm gonna circ i'm gonna
highlight it red and that means all the
edges that are outgoing from that
individual get also highlighted as red
and the measured outcome now is going to
be let's say that the measured outcome
at uh
node 3 is going to be its baseline alpha
3 plus the sum of all the weights of
incoming red edges so any edge that is
activated or i'm calling activated or
red it means that that the the source of
that edge was treated
so let me tell you why i think this
model is a good one
um first of all it does allow for full
heterogeneity so as chris mentioned
here's the alphas the betas the gammas
they all are are kind of indexed uh and
so the total number of parameters in
this model are two times n plus the
number of edges that is clearly more
than the number of possible measurements
so it's i that's why i call this a
non-parametric model because um the you
can't you know even as you grow the size
of your data set and uh your model
complexity grows along with this so that
you never are in the setting where you
can fully identify the model
um
also this model can capture uh
endogenous peer effects such as
contingent what that means is
um if you have a setting where my
outcome is actually affected not by
other people's treatment by other but by
other people's outcomes
but in a linear way you can kind of
take this
this linear relationship right as a
system of equations solve the system of
linear equations and you end up getting
kind of a model that looks the same as
the one we had in the top but now with a
different graph structure in particular
uh if you had a sparse graph on the
uh on this line you might end up getting
a fully dense graph on the bottom line
right so a
linear outcomes model um it can
uh mod it can capture things like pure
effects but in contagion but you have to
keep them
in mind that it changes the
the meaning of the graph
and and you can easily add
independent measurement noise as well
okay so let me tell you why this result
works so again i'll summarize the
results and i explain the intuition
the result is that given knowledge of
the average bass lines alpha bar for any
randomized design such that the um
the the marginal again marginal
probability uh probability of treating
an individual is equal to p so i'm going
again there's some there's some kind of
uniform of balance condition i need then
the following simple estimator which is
the one i described earlier it kind of
does this simple scaling by one over p
of the average total outcomes
minus this alpha baseline this quantity
is unbiased and it's
i'm going to call it efficient estimator
and i'll explain to you why uh i think
why my interpretation for the variance
is an efficient one for any network
under the heterogeneous linear outcomes
model so
critically i want to comment that two
well one the randomized design is really
easy for newly randomized design you
can't get easier than that two
um computing this estimator is also not
like super easy and that it doesn't
require me to know knowledge of the
network two it didn't even actually use
the
realization of the treatment vector
right i just did a naive average over
all the outcomes i didn't even wait by
if it's treated or not so this is like
a really easy estimator to compute
so let me give you the intuition for why
the result helds actually it's very easy
to see from the graph and
um
so once you think so for this
heterogeneous linear outcome model when
you view as a graph you can actually
think of the total treatment effect as
the sum of the weighted edges
so um
so in particular if you write out the
total treatment effect subtract out the
base lines right then you get exactly
the sum of all the self edges and also
all the all the edges across
and treating an individual activates its
outgoing edges
and the estimator when you write it out
and rearrange it a little bit you can
show this estimator is nothing but the
sum of these activated edges
so
i'm going to rearrange this expression a
little bit and now i've written the
estimator it's it's actually exactly
equivalent to this expression where
um this term in the parentheses i'm
actually going to call the influence and
uh so in particular it's for zi
individual i if he's treated
um uh
the coefficient the thing that's
multiplied in front of zi is beta i the
direct effect of the individual being
treated plus the sum over all
individuals k of gamma ik so there was
is actually a transpose happening here
so gamma ik is representing the the uh
the network effect that individual i has
on individual k and so what this
influence parameter is it's the sum of
the outgoing edges of individual i
uh and so
what this means is that
under this model you can reduce
estimating total treatment effect to
just estimating some population mean for
a super simple model in particular here
on the left uh you know in our original
model you can see the total treatment
effect um is this quantity here if i
relabel this thing in parentheses to the
influence l i then on the right it's the
it's just this uh scaled
average of the li across the entire
population the influence terms of god's
population
that's the estimator sorry as skilled uh
and it's i measure my estimator kind of
estimates it for every individual that's
treated um the quantity that i want to
estimate is just the sum of the
influence terms across the entire
population
so
you can think of on the uh on the left
you kind of have this complicated graph
it's not complicated the simple graph
picture where you can see by treating a
node i'm activating it's out going edges
but what i'm measuring is i'm measuring
like my treatment activates outgoing
edges but my measurements measure
measure incoming edges but it's okay
because when i sum it all up i'm just
summing activated edges right and so
it's it's kind of
the same thing that's happening in the
picture on the right where i have just a
population each individual has some
quantity l i and then i
sample a subset of the individuals a p
fraction of them to observe
uh and then you know i use the fraction
value sample to estimate the mean of the
whole thing right so on the right hand
side we just reduced to literally the
same like estimation of a population
mean that is like super studied and
everything is invented right there's no
network inference on the right
so the the i guess the punch line is
that given baseline estimates network
causal inference as is as easy as
estimating a population mean uh when you
have linearity
um so you can show unbiasedness
and you can calculate the variance again
using this relationship and so my
comment on why this is the efficient
estimator because uh you know if i was
in this simple setting on the right of
course the best thing i can do if i have
a population i'm trying to estimate the
mean i sample a subset of them and then
i like you know estimate the the
empirical mean like
that's sufficient efficient thing to do
you know and that you can't really do
better than this uh you know one over p
n scaling in terms of the
variance depends uh it depends on this
the inherent variance in these influence
terms oh
not
they're actually not overlapping because
because i'm assuming in this
heterogeneous linear outcomes model i
have a directed graph
so the edges they're directed and in
that sense the uh the l i's are the
outgoing edges so the outgoing edges are
not overlapping
but one node
has
okay so you're assuming the edges are
independent
um i am assuming the edges haven't each
have an arbitrary weight
but they're not treated independently
and that like the node are the ones that
are treated so the edges uh outgoing
from the same node are all coupled
because that node is treated or not and
so every edge coming out from the same
note is coupled
but uh but the outcomes of multiple
nodes are going to be core
yes so the outcomes
are correlated your estimator will have
like cross terms that have to show up in
a variance calculator yes but the nice
thing is that it's because you can
rearrange
your so here uh
uh here is how you calculate your
estimator it's by sending over the y's
but i can rearrange
the this estimator and rewrite it it's
exactly equivalent to so i can't
actually compute the influence parameter
i don't know what it is but but the
estimator what it computes is exactly
the same as
what i would have computed if i knew the
influence power i only summed the
influence parameters for individuals
that were treated
i think to solve a quick
sorry
well i was just wondering how you
actually calculate the variance because
the expression you've had was in terms
of the ls but maybe that's
oh uh
yeah oh sorry we can move on
okay well all right well i'm gonna move
on and maybe happy to take that question
because uh yeah so but but the i think
that the key idea is that actually um
you can analyze everything as if you
were analyzing the model on the right
you cannot actually calculate the model
on the right because i don't know i
don't for my data i don't know my allies
but when i sum them all up the outcomes
up the sum of the outcomes is actually
the sum of the else of the of the
activated nodes
it seems like this doesn't really need
to be the graph structure as you said
and it should transfer to other
constraints like low rank
using the matrices low rank or anything
that constrains the complexity of these
linear functions
um should give you some result where
like instead of the degree you get
ranked for some other things to show
yes um so
um actually maybe i'll move on to
there's some extensions
and i
so i have partial answer to that and i
think
maybe more later but but um
i do have we are able to extend it
beyond linear uh we can extend to low
degree polynomials um
low rate i think
potentially but with linear but like a
constraint
of the matrix other than locality oh
okay matrix constraint that says you
don't have like square yes yes yes yes
okay that's a great question so i
thought about that and i would love a
result like that
the thing that i'm not sure how to get
is that um at the end of the day my
measurements i only have n measurements
and so i somehow have to critically use
the randomness of the randomized design
in my matrix estimation and i right now
i don't know of good techniques that can
do that for major assassination but i
think that's a really great question i
would love to figure that out um yeah so
i mean so i'm happy to end on this slide
i guess my comment was that we do have
extensions one beyond linear two low
degree polynomials and we also do have
extensions uh when you actually don't
even know alpha bar so i i explained the
intuition's cleanest and the one i
explained
but when you don't know the this alpha
bar um the the bass lines there is also
something you can do where you can
construct an estimator you do need to
know the graph there uh but you're able
to get an estimator that skills like one
over p n and there's a polynomial
dependence on the degree um
yeah so i guess i'll leave it at that
happy two questions
great let's think yes
one or two short questions here
another question which is are you
assuming that the wives are independent
but for the interference effect
um
what
what i'm assuming is that like my only
all the randomness in the model in the
in when i compute bias and variance is
purely from the randomized design okay
the i'm not assuming any probabilistic
model on the weights or anything so
they're fully arbitrary okay
so i had one question and maybe as i
asked it we can switch uh speakers here
um the question i had was if we know the
baseline
so if we know the sum
of the y zeros and we said oh i don't
have to know
the graph or anything i have a very
simple type of estimator then the
variance can be bounded
i know of a design and an s estimator
that has variance zero i i i must have
missed something
because i could just assign everyone to
treatment and then i observe all the
treatment so if i have all the baseline
i'm done and the variance is zero what
if i what have i missed here oh i'm kind
of assuming that if you have a budget on
your tree different treated fraction so
i'm only i only give you a budget that
you're only allowed to treat in your
experiment so here we were thinking i
mean the the collaborative i worked with
at that time was consulting for linkedin
experimentation platform and the idea is
that you know i want to test something
and linkedin says you know when you're
running these randomized trials like at
most you can test on two percent of my
traffic like i don't want you to you
know
treat everyone okay yeah that totally
clears that one up awesome great thank
you and let's let's uh thank uh chris